hallo leute heute möchten wir euch
einige nützliche setzte vorstellen die
in telefonaten hören werdet und nutzen
können zu beginn möchte ich euch etwas
empfehlen wenn ihr noch nicht so gut
deutsch sprechen könnt solltet ihr das
die person am telefon direkt zu beginn
des gesprächs wissen lassen so kam sich
euer gegenüber darauf einstellen und zum
beispiel langsamer sprechen
daher zeige ich euch nun fünf sätze mit
denen ihr ausdrucken könnt dass ihr die
sprache noch lernt oder die ihr nutzen
könnt wenn ihr etwas nicht versteht
mein deutsch ist noch nicht so gut
können sie bitte langsam sprechen
das habe ich nicht verstanden
könnten sie das bitte noch einmal
wiederholen
ich habe nicht verstanden was sie damit
meinen könnten sie das noch einmal
genauer erklären
dieses wort kenne ich nicht
können sie mir erklären was das heißt
mein deutsch ist noch nicht so gut
können wir bitte auf englisch sprechen
nun zeigen wir euch anhand von zwei
telefongesprächen einige typische sätze
die euch in telefonaten immer mal wieder
begegnen werden
diese hoffnung bei ihrem zahnarzt an um
einen termin ausmachen
guten tag hier ist isabelle schmidt ich
möchte gerne einen termin vereinbaren
ich möchte gerne einen termin
vereinbaren
guten tag frau schmidt waren sie schon
einmal bei uns in der praxis waren sie
schon einmal bei uns in der praxis ja
ich bin patientin bei ihnen dann nennen
sie mir doch bitte einmal ihr
geburtsdatum
dann nennen sie mir doch bitte einmal
ihr geburtsdatum
ja das ist der erste erste 1999 kommen
sie für einen kontrolltermin oder haben
sie beschwerden kommen sie für einen
kontrolltermin oder haben sie
beschwerden
ich habe seit einigen tagen
zahnschmerzen wenn sie akut schmerzen
haben können sie zu unserer die
notfallsprechstunde kommen diese ist
montags bis freitags von 9 bis 12 uhr am
besten kommen sie direkt um 9 uhr und
bringen etwas wartezeit mit sie können
in die notfallsprechstunde kommen
bitte bringen sie etwas wartezeit mit
vielen dank dann komme ich morgen früh
in die praxis könnte ich auch noch einen
termin für eine zahnreinigung
vereinbaren könnte ich auch einen termin
vereinbaren
ja natürlich an welchen tagen und zu
welcher uhrzeit passt es bei ihm gut
ich bin recht flexibel aber gerne
vormittags am 13 januar um 10 uhr
das passt vielen dank ok ich trage den
termin 1
bis dahin ich trage den termin 1
möchtet ihr eure aussprache verbessern
um euch für solche gespräche
vorzubereiten dann probiert doch mal
unsere app siedlung aus dort haben wir
zum beispiel einen aussprache trainer in
dem ihr eure eigene aussprache aufnehmen
und anschließend mit der aussprache
eines muttersprachler
reichen könnte auf diese weise könnt ihr
euer gesprochenes deutsch schritt für
schritt verbessern
kommen wir nun zu einer zweiten
situation
sie hatte extra noch pünktlich vor
weihnachten ein geschenk für mich
bestellt
aber dieses ist nicht angekommen ruft
bei dem geschäft an um sich zu
beschweren
guten tag und herzlich willkommen bei
dein perfektes weihnachtsgeschenk 24 de
gerne helfen wir ihnen bei ihrem
anliegen drücken sie die taste 1 wenn
sie eine frage zu unseren produkten
haben drücken die taste zwei wenn sie
eine frage zu ihrem konto haben
drücken sie tastet drei wenn sie direkt
mit einem mitarbeiter verbunden werden
möchten
momentan sind alle unsere leitungen
belegt bitte haben sie einen moment
geduld wir sind gleich persönlich für
sie da haben sie schon unsere webseite
dein perfektes weihnachtsgeschenk 24 de
besucht ihr anliegen ist uns wichtig
bitte bleiben sie in der leitung
sie werden so schnell wie möglich
verbunden bitte warten sie noch einen
augenblick der nächste freie mitarbeiter
ist sofort für sie der tag hier ist der
kundenservice vom da ein perfektes
weihnachtsgeschenk 24 de hier ist janine
wie kann ich dir helfen ja guten tag
meine bestellung ist leider nicht
angekommen ich habe extra für den
express lieferservice bezahlt und mein
paket sollte noch vor weihnachten
gekommen ist es aber nicht und ich bin
wirklich unzufrieden möchte mich
beschweren
ich möchte mich beschweren
das tut mir wirklich leid können sie mir
ihre kundennummer und ihre bestellen
immer na ja meine kundennummer es 37 89
54 vp bindestrich mm und die kommt man
ganz nach die bestellnummer es 2020 12
3 89 74 ok ich sehe gerade dass ihr
paket in einem zwischenlager anders
kurierdienstes liegt das darf natürlich
nicht passieren entschuldigen sie die
unannehmlichkeiten entschuldigen sie die
unannehmlichkeiten
möchten sie die bestellung noch erhalten
oder darf in die kosten zurückerstatten
darf ich ihnen die kosten
zurückerstatten
ja ich möchte die bestellung noch
erhalten
ok dann erstatten die kosten für den
express lieferservice und schicke die
bestellung umgeht noch einmal an silos
wir möchten uns gerne zusätzlich mit
einem 15 euro gutschein bei ihnen
entschuldigen
sie erhalten einen gutschein von uns
okay das ist in ordnung
vielen dank kein problem wir danken
ihnen ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen tag
ich würde mich freuen wenn sie noch kurz
in der leitung bleiben und unser
gespräch bewerben
auf wiederhören ich hoffe euch haben
diese beiden kleinen szenen geholfen ihr
vokabular auch für telefongespräche
weiter auszubauen
und wie ich bereits sagte schaut euch
mal unsere app sieht länge und den
aussprache trainer an
um eure aussprache schritt für schritt
zu verbessern bis bald kommen sie für
einen kontrolltermin oder haben sie
beschwerten anna david payne 2 32 hier
ist termin wie kann ich dir helfen